I'm going to talk to you today
about sea slugs and solar power.
My background and what I do --
I'm an invertebrate zoologist.
So invertebrate animals are animals
that don't have a backbone.
So this is actually most
of the animals on the planet.
It ranges from things like insects
to clams to sea sponges to worms.
And a great other many things
that we don't have time
to talk about today.
On our planet, most of the biological
energy that we have available
comes, ultimately, from the sun.
The process from this
being converted to solar energy,
to biological energy is photosynthesis.
You’re probably familiar with this
as something that plants do.
And all of the food that we eat
ultimately comes from photosynthesis,
either us directly eating plants
or eating animals that eat plants.
And that's really where all of the energy
that all of the animals have comes from.
However, there are a few animals
that have managed to get around that
and become photosynthetic themselves
and are able to capture
the energy from the sun,
convert it into biological energy, right?
So just like plants, they take
carbon dioxide in sunlight,
turn it into sugar and oxygen.
The best and most famous example
of this are the corals.
The photos that we're looking at here
are some some corals
from the Red Sea in Egypt
and from a reef in Cuba.
All the photos I'm going to share
with you today are photographs I've taken.
And when I've gotten
photos from the field,
I put the location there,
if you're interested.
The photos from the laboratory
won't be labeled like that.
They have a black background on them.
Corals are able to photosynthesize
because of a special partnership,
a symbiosis that they have
with a single-celled algae
called zooxanthellae.
The algae live inside
of cells of the coral,
capture the sunlight
and provide the corals with sugar.
So effectively we have
photosynthetic animals.
This is unusual,
but actually occurs
in quite a lot of the corals
and many of their relatives,
and actually happens in a fair number
of other animals as well.
So we see this in things
like some sea sponges,
we see this in some flatworms,
and we see it in other animals
closely related to corals
like sea anemones and jellyfish.
So this is an upside down jellyfish.
This is an organism that, just like
the corals we were talking about,
has these zooxanthellae inside of them
and can photosynthesize.
So this animal lives in like,
shallow mangroves throughout the world
and just lays on the bottom,
capturing sunlight.
I keep a few in my laboratory
that I use for teaching,
and I don't actually have to feed them.
I just give them light
from one of my aquarium lights,
and I’ve managed to keep
some of them there for two years.
And I use them in my invertebrate
zoology courses.
I like the jellyfish, though,
even though the coral is perhaps
a more famous example.
The jellyfish is nice because we can
take a tentacle of a jellyfish
and look at it under the microscope,
and that allows us to see this process.
So this is a micrograph,
a microscopic photograph I've taken,
of some zooxanthellae from the tentacle
of the upside-down jellyfish Cassiopeia.
And I did this back
at my laboratory in Tampa.
And all of those little golden brown
spheres that we're seeing,
each one of those is one
of those algal cells.
So they're loaded in there quite densely.
There's a lot of them there.
So these animals are able
to photosynthesize that way.
So it's quite remarkable
that we have animals
that are not doing
the typical animal thing.
The jellyfish can still feed,
and in the wild, they do.
But they can get most
of their energy just from the sun.
Fantastic.
I primarily study a group
of organisms called mollusks.
Mollusks are probably familiar
to some of you,
if, because of nothing else,
because of their shells
and in some cases as food.
So these include animals
like snails and clams.
Also things like octopus and squids
and some other strange things
that we won't have time to go into today.
But the mollusks are
a fantastically diverse group.
They are the second most diverse group
of animals on the planet
after the arthropods,
which win out because of the insects.
But in terms of sheer
diversity in body form,
the mollusks, I would argue,
are in fact the most diverse
and range from things
smaller than grains of rice
to colossal squids
that are absolutely enormous.
And we have photosynthesis
within our mollusks as well.
So these are giant clams.
They're fantastically beautiful animals.
They live in tropical coral reefs
in the Indo-Pacific, primarily.
And when I say giant, there's a range.
Some of the species aren't quite so large,
but some of them are absolutely enormous,
and they’re beautiful.
And a lot of the coloration
we're seeing in some of these
comes from their symbiotic algae.
They have the same zooxanthellae
that we saw within the corals.
Unfortunately, giant clams
are rather difficult to see in the wild.
They've been overharvested in many areas
because people want their large shells
and they are also eaten.
That's a very interesting symbiosis too.
But the group that I'm most interested in
are called the gastropods.
Gastropods are snails and slugs.
So your typical garden snail
that you may be familiar with
and many of the seashells
that you may have collected
visiting the beach
come from gastropods.
So this is a tremendously diverse
group of mollusks.
They're the most diverse group of mollusks
in terms of number of species.
Quite a large number of them.
And they're fantastically interesting.
I wish we had time to go
into more of them here.
The one in the middle is a cone snail,
one of the most venomous
animals on the planet.
And also a ...
subject of a great deal
of biomedical research
studying the potential of its venom.
But my real passion is slugs.
My favorite thing to do is go scuba diving
in a tropical coral reef
and look for sea slugs.
And a sea slug, ultimately, or any slug,
is a snail that, over the course
of evolution, has lost its shell.
So a slug is just a snail
minus the shell, right?
And this has happened multiple times.
This was not a single evolutionary event,
but one that occurred over and over again.
And so we have multiple
unrelated groups of snails
that have either greatly reduced or lost
their shell over the course of evolution.
There's a few of them shown here,
just to show you some variety.
This includes the head shield slugs.
There are sea hares as well as
the pulmonates, or air-breathing, slugs,
which may show up in your garden
and cause you a great deal of displeasure.
Now, the most common question that I get
when I tell people what I do
for a living, studying slugs,
is, “Why would you do that?
Why study slugs?
You could do anything.
Why do that?"
And I think the best way to explain this
to you all is not to tell you,
but to show you.
So here are some of the slugs
I've encountered in my travels.
They are fantastically weird.
They're fantastically beautiful.
They do some very strange things.
There’s a lot of really interesting
biology going on with these animals.
And there’s so much that we don’t know.
Many slugs,
the only scientific paper written
on them is a species description.
And there's many more out there
that haven't even been described.
So there's so much for us to learn
and so much that we don't know.
It's just wide open
and so fascinating to me.
Now, in the ocean,
there are many types of slugs.
I've sort of shown you that already.
There's two groups
that I'm going to tell you about now.
One group is probably
the most famous of them
and certainly the most diverse
in terms of total number of species,
are the nudibranchs.
And that name, “nudi,” means naked,
but "branch" means gills.
So it's referring to those feathery tufts
that we're seeing on these animals.
They're beautiful, they're diverse,
they're interesting,
and they're carnivores.
They eat other animals, mostly --
they are slugs, right,
so they’re not chasing things down.
They eat other slow things.
So sometimes other slugs,
they also eat things like sponges
and in some cases,
relatives of our corals,
like sea anemones.
And some of these nudibranchs that do that
are able to take those zooxanthellae
that we were talking about earlier,
put them inside of their own cells,
and then they become photosynthetic.
So they steal their photosynthesis.
They're excellent thieves.
Some of them even steal the stinging cells
out of jellyfish and anemones
and use them for their own defense.
Absolutely fantastic.
This is my favorite group of slugs.
These are the sacoglossan sea slugs.
They are also thieves.
They are, you may notice, green, right?
Some of them are green for camouflage,
but many of them are green
for a very different reason.
These slugs are herbivores,
and they have a special
single little tooth,
and they just poke
one little hole into the algae,
and then they slurp out
the contents inside of it.
And they take some of those contents
and they digest them.
But others, the chloroplasts,
which are the organelles
inside of a plant cell
that allows plants to photosynthesize,
the slugs take those and stick them
inside of their own cells,
and then they become photosynthetic.
We call this kleptoplasty.
"Klepto", as in to steal,
"plasty" as in chloroplast, right?
So they've stolen chloroplasts.
And these slugs, it varies,
some of them can only do this
for a couple of days,
but some can do this for many months,
even complete their entire life cycle.
Let's take a little bit closer look
at the digestive track
of one of these slugs.
This is a photo
by my colleague Nick Curtis.
And this is showing us the digestive
tubules of these animals.
So their digestive track
is highly branched.
It goes in many different directions.
And at the end of these branches,
we have these cul de sacs
that are loaded with chloroplasts.
If we look closer at a single cell
in one of these cul de sacs,
also a photo by my colleague Nick Curtis,
we see a single cell here.
That's what we're looking at,
that structure labeled N.
That is the nucleus of the cell.
But all of those structures labeled C
and everything that looks like them,
those circles, those are chloroplasts,
and they're jammed in there
so tight and so dense
that there's more
chloroplasts in that cell
than you would find in the algae,
at least in terms of density.
This is wonderful.
These animals have stolen photosynthesis,
and you can see some of them
kind of look like leafs, right?
They're super green,
they're fantastically photosynthetic.
And how they do this
is somewhat of a mystery.
Taking a chloroplast
and sticking inside of a cell
is not enough to become photosynthetic.
Chloroplasts need things
that the algae provide to them
that animals shouldn’t be able to do.
And we've started to unravel some of this.
And this is a slow process
and something that we're just
really scratching the surface of.
But one of the things that we've
discovered for the two slugs shown here,
the emerald sea slug,
which can photosynthesize
for its entire adult life cycle,
nine months after one meal.
And the lettuce sea slug,
which lives throughout the Caribbean
and the primary one I study,
photosynthesizes three
or four months after a meal.
Both of these animals
are able to make chlorophyll,
which is one of the chemicals
that is needed
for photosynthesis to occur.
And animals should not be able to do this.
But somehow these slugs
have managed to do it.
And so this is one of the things
that I find really exciting
and that we're trying to unravel.
But there's so many things
that we still don't know about this.
So many questions we haven't even
thought of yet to ask.
What's going on here
at the cellular level?
What's happening at the molecular level?
What's happening
at the biochemical level?
We're starting to get the answers
to these questions.
But there's so much we don't know yet.
Why are some of them blue?
I have no idea.
But some of our slugs are occasionally
this wonderful blue color,
something we hope to someday figure out.
So I hope you've enjoyed
this introduction to sea slugs.
I hope this leaves you
curious to learn more
about slugs and other invertebrates.
There's just so much that we don't know
and so much out there for us to learn.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)